[Music]
have you every single one of you and
it's just it's so great to be here and I
got it I got a I got a say some a few
words about this guy to my left
Conan Carlin Conan you're the only talk
show who let me come on to promote my
book and I tried all of them Donahue
Magic Johnson show the phone was
disconnected how you people yeah I mean
come on yeah we talked about the phone
and we wanted to get sure it was
lickety-split yes it was yes this is
exciting you have a you have a book out
and I don't think I've ever seen this
before
you have a testimonial that you wrote
yourself in the front of the book I've
seen a lot of people promoting a lot of
books I've never seen the author put
their own testimonial on the front of
the book you know that's what the
critics were eventually gonna say and I
just beat him to the punch you know and
it is it's a hell of a book it's a real
page-turner
it's a yeah and it's a hundred and
thirty percent true oh wow that sounds
almost mathematically impossible every
it's I literally poured my soul into it
yeah it's I go deep yet you do I I look
through this there's a lot of helpful
tips there are there many different
varying chapters yes and what's
fascinating is that there's some tips in
here that I wouldn't expect them to come
from the newsman one is how to survive a
prison riot yes
you write about that yes I've spent a
number of times in prison being at being
an investigative journalist yeah mostly
in South America you had some helpful
tips I'd say 12 tips to surviving a
prison riot and you know basic ones like
of course make homemade weapons Shiv you
know whatever you know a comb with a
little you know a baby tooth on the end
of it baby keep a satchel a small statue
a baby that's probably my best tip is
tip number eight
always keep your own poop in your cell
with you what do you mean keep it with
you bags of your own poop collect it
throughout your stay and just have it
ready because if if it goes down I mean
there's nothing crazier than if this guy
stained in poop running after you put it
over yourself oh if I hear any sort of
trouble I just start rubbing it all over
and I just come with people no one wants
to fight you know no one wants to fight
you I believe you right now that just
baked in your own liquid feces yes yes
that would Andy too if like you were at
a car dealership and didn't want to get
bothered by salesmen yeah yeah yeah I
wanted to drive down the price exactly I
won't leave until you lower this right
now Ron I'm curious you have another one
you eat a chapter what's wrong with
America yes you wrote a chapter what's
wrong in America and I was surprised by
one of the answers you said babies yes
babies have gotten uglier in this
country babies America gotten ugly well
I don't think it's a fact in fact you do
wouldn't bring a baby tonight no they're
not allowed to be in here I proved my
point
you don't one of those little ugly
suckers staring back at you all
googly-eyed see what you think whole
babies in America are ugly oh yeah in
the 50s there were good-looking babies
but nowadays I don't know what happened
I do know this I've never seen an ugly
Thai baby you say the Taiwanese have
wonderful little the people from
Thailand the Thai people that's high
people beautiful babies gorgeous yeah
gorgeous yeah if there was a baby
calendar of beautiful babies most of the
months would be dominated by Thai babies
okay Wow
it's an incredible prediction there's a
picture you have the picture of me yes
we have you as a baby you were quite a
baby yeah what I'm talking about it's a
good-looking baby you were a fantastic
baby which brings me to my next question
the hair turned out to be a pretty
good-looking adult if I don't mind my
save myself no you don't seem to mind at
all
you
you have which cameras on yeah
a red one yeah there you go it's the one
with the red light yes yeah no I know
that yeah you've been in TV a long time
mm-hmm